while back got a visit from unbelievable
rocker mr alice cooper himself there he
is
the man the myth the legend himself
alice cooper you bought me a cool car
season 10 of counting cars premiered
this week you can see danny coker and
the rest of the crew every wednesday on
the history channel plus you can see
danny and his band performing tomorrow
night at m resort let's welcome back
it's danny coker good to see you buddy
always a pleasure always a pleasure oh
my god i love you so much thank you man
you are the best i'll be right back
right there absolutely we can do it fast
for 20 minutes absolutely y'all can just
hang out with us we got stuff to talk
about let's talk about that first
episode yeah and alice cooper's car
avanti am i saying that right 63 avanti
studebaker avanti rare well i was there
the day that car arrived you and i were
doing some stuff and i saw that car and
it was in bad shape when that thing came
in how long does a build like that take
uh i'm going to say the better part of a
year yeah to be honest with you yeah but
but for alice we went crazy he wanted it
to appear very much like a factory 63
avanti but he wanted it to be daily
drivable fun you know car so it was
everything under the skin was replaced i
mean the whole everything underneath is
modern brand new get in turn the key
drive it every day but it still looks
like a 63 avanti it is gorgeous what do
you guys want you have to see the
episode where do you see it you bring it
out of your garage and it's stunning
what's the fastest build you ever did
wow uh as far as time turns yeah someone
says i need this done i need it done man
i think i think we probably have have
completed uh complete builds in a matter
of a few months in a matter of probably
three months
it's a very fast turnaround and uh we we
really don't like to do it that way
because uh we like to be a little bit
more meticulous
mistakes can happen in
a quick thing but you know a little bit
more time is always better but we can if
if we stopped everything in the shop and
everybody focus on one vehicle we could
turn it around a few months i heard
something about you a friend told me did
you watch that's true well did you once
get a speeding ticket in front of wayne
lew's house oh absolutely absolutely uh
it was uh my gosh that's hilarious i
don't even told you that it was it
wasn't even a speeding ticket i had i
didn't have a driver's license i was a
kid okay and i was riding a dirt bike
on the street but this was you know back
in the day
and i was going to a friend's house and
i was just bombing it down the road and
i got i got pulled over uh by by our
wonderful metro which which are 100
support and uh and they were very very
nice to me and uh wrote me a ticket
because number one the bike was illegal
number two i was a kid and didn't have a
driver's license and all this kind of
stuff but number three once he wrote the
ticket he sent me on my way
absolutely
we got about a minute here okay just
real quick uh tomorrow night your band
count 77 m resort what kind of music do
you guys play we are a 70s hard rock
band so when you come to a count 77 show
you're going to get original music
because we're signed with shrapnel
records we got two original records out
working on our third right now so you're
going to get original hard rock music
that sounds like it's from the 70s but
then you're also going to get some big
famous 70s hard rock tunes that you love
as well so when you come to account 77
show be prepared to just go back in time
and get your face melted it's going to
be a hard rock and roll show that's
tomorrow night at the m it's going to be
a great show you can see danny in his
band i got a present for you oh nick is
our intern nick come on out here nick
what's happening bro we got uh something
here for daddy oh dude this is tradition
this is for you and i'll let you show
the camera show the camera i love it all
right this is this is this is tradition
tradition
for for us we always take pictures of us
together if you look you see that photo
of us holding another photo of us
holding another photo of us holding
another it's it's like it's like an
eternal thing yeah it's our thing i do
have a question about this for did i was
like at your birthday party or something
look at all this is all these presents i
have for you what is going on here i
don't remember i think it was your
birthday i don't remember you and i had
some cake we celebrated something i was
so much younger then i almost looked
like you i was so young this is like six
months ago you kidding me all right so
county cars wednesday night history
channel and then tomorrow night danny
and his band count 77 and resort amen
thank you so
much over to you